Yeah,
I thought that was on a paper view.
That's right.
Yeah,
you're right.
I'm sorry it's doing my thing.
But that fight was really like a top contender.
If,
I mean chaos,
uh,
had been on a roll.
He's very strong on the ground,
which is one of the reasons why it was so impressive that he took his back and
choked him like that.
Yeah.
I mean I think I have a different style than,
than uh,
a lot of people can see,
you know,
you,
you go back to could be and,
and all this.
I like,
his style is,
it's good.
It's obviously very good,
but I can see a lot of holes in it.
And I saw those holes many years ago.
I've been called how big he could beat for years.
I've been wanting to fight them just because people got those questions.
I've got those questions too.
So I'm like,
let's see what this motherfucker got.
Like,
cause I see it,
I see them hoes,
you know,
I don't really focus on too much of the good.
I'm like,
what holes?
That boy number,
I'll tell you.
What are the holes?
What do you see?
You know,
even on some of his take on a lot of his takedowns,
he misses a lot of them.
You know,
he's very square.
He kinda just bum rushes.
You know,
people were talking about the Barboza fight before and they're like,
are you looking at that fighter and you're going to try and build off that one?
I'm like,
yeah.
I mean he did.
Okay.
The fight was good.
He beat the hell out of Barboza,
but I saw the holes in it.
You know,
he's just running square forward.
Adam,
you know,
he got hit with a lot of shots.
I didn't see people in the outside watching him because the way he just came
forward on Barboza was like he was indestructable.
Yeah,
I mean it didn't matter.
I'm just going to get you,
it's just a matter of time.
Keep throwing your kicks.
I'm going to get you.
I'm going to get you you.
I got you.
You got those guys.
But the body gives up.
You know,
you got Justin Gates,
you as the same way the body will give up and met with you.
You can't keep putting your body on the line like that.
I mean,
if he wants to run at me square for it,
a square like that,
that's what I'm getting paid.
I'm getting paid.
Oh,
sorry.
I love the,
I love watching him fight,
but part of me is like,
Jesus,
man.